[Applause]
welcome to PMT ot on yahoo sports peter
king Mike Florio talking about the big
issues in the NFL one of the biggest
issues the status of Patrick my homes we
don't know how long he's gonna be out
but he's at least out for the immediate
future Peter with Patrick mahomes
injured which team is now the biggest
threat in your estimation to the
Patriots in the AFC I think it's the
Baltimore Ravens I think right now you
look for a team in October that you say
that team is gonna be significantly
better in December and that's the way
the Patriots operate their franchise
every year they're playing in October
but they're looking at January and I
think that's what Eric DeCoste and John
Harbaugh are doing with this team at
this time let's get our quarterback
ready to go let's get him familiar with
both passing and running in you know to
maximize both that he can do and our
defense even though it looks like
they've lost Pernell McPhee now their
defense is a growing proposition along
with acquiring Marcus Peters so I think
the Baltimore Ravens right now are the
biggest threat to take advantage of that
and look let's say that the Chiefs lose
a game or two and then all of a sudden
they're the three seed and and and if
Baltimore's the two seed all of a sudden
it's not impossible but it's a different
game playing in January at the crabcake
than it is playing in Kansas City and
the Ravens one of the few teams that can
match up really well for whatever reason
with the Patriots they've won in
Foxborough a couple of times in the
postseason under John Harbaugh the
concern I have though is the team gets
better
Peter pointing towards January that risk
of Lamar Jackson getting injured is not
going to go away he takes way too many
hits he doesn't slide he doesn't avoid
contact at some point he's going to get
injured and then it's gonna be the king
of the reckless physical quarterback rg3
who comes in as the backup but that's my
big concern with Baltimore can Lamar
Jackson make it to the point where
they're gonna cash in on this team that
is systematically getting better and oh
by the way week 9 Sunday night
ball hits the Patriots at the Ravens and
look the Patriots adding Mohamed Sanu
now not next week at the trade deadline
getting him now maybe get him up to
speed for that Ravens game because I
think the Patriots know they're gonna
have their hands full during the regular
season against the Ravens and and who
knows maybe that's the outcome that
determines if there is a postseason
rematch where that rematch occurs you
know Lamar Jackson if he goes down Mike
all bets are off
then we're looking at the next team then
we're looking at let's say the
Indianapolis Colts who you know
conveniently have a tiebreaker edge
against Kansas City right now
and Baltimore does not so I think that's
significant the one other thing I would
one other point I would make about
Baltimore I find it really odd based on
when I was there in training camp I'll
tell you this was not a training camp to
watch Lamar Jackson run you know he was
being it was being stressed you know
let's throw it let's throw it let's not
overboard the run and again look I don't
know why they've changed a month ago he
told the New York Times I hate running
and and now all of a sudden he's on pace
to run for 1,300 yards all I know is
that it's fun to watch and he's really
playing great right now all around but
you're absolutely right he's got to make
it through two and a half more months
before he plays the game against the
Patriots that would really count the
Texans are a team to keep an eye on if
they can get things straight against the
Colts and the other teams in their
division and win enough games to qualify
it looks like maybe they could also the
bills in the AFC East they've got the
best record other than the Patriots
right now and they played the Patriots
tough but the Bills have won a lot of
close games this year against some teams
that you would call inferior they're
gonna have to keep threading the needle
week in and week out to have a shot at
toppling the Patriots in the AFC East
and obviously you have to beat him in
the division before you have any
semblance of hosting games in the
postseason of being a real threat to
advance to the Super Bowl
that's it for this edition of pft ot
check us out for more on Yahoo Sports
throughout the 2019 NFL season
you
[Music]
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports